37,2, température normale
Les amis bienvenue dans cette video, aujourd'hui c'est une video géniale
On est content avec Clément. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on est dans une clinique vétérinaire
Le métier que tout les petits enfant rêvent de faire entre 4 et 8 ans
Toi aussi t'as voulu être vétérinaire ?
J'voulais être pompier
Ah, c'est pas pareil !
Les amis, j'ai un ami qui s'appelle docteur michael
Ok,  j'fais un nom américain c'est plus stylé mais il s'apelle vraiment Mickael, en français
J'ai de la chance parce que cette ami detient plusieurs cliniques vétérinaires sur Paris
Je suis passé le voir plusieurs fois dans ses cliniques pour boire un café avec lui, parler et tout
Et en fait à chaque fois que je passais, il se passait des trucs dans la clinique, des trucs typiques de vétos
Que je trouvais incroyables, je lui ai donc demandé si c'était possible un jour de passer vraiment 24 heures dans sa clinique avec lui avec une blouse de vétérinaire comme lui
Ok, avec son petit logo, c'est mignon. Moi j'ai trop hâte de voir tout ça, alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on enfile cette blouse, qui apparemment est trop grande pour moi d'après Mickael
Bah c'est une blouse ricaine quoi, on a un petit style ricain.
Bon, Mickael est actuellement en consultation, du coup en attendant, je sais pas trop quoi faire !
J'pense que je vais pratiquer un peu avec ce... cet instrument
C'est pas grand chose, c'est de la petite toux, on lui file un doliprane 1000 et sa ira mieux, hein ?
MICKAEL, Mickael arrive, vous l'avez vu, il est beau, il est très beau, lui dites pas après il complexe
Bienvenue docteur Mickael, comment tu vas mon gars ?
Je suis très content d'être la aujourd'hui ! Tu fais sa depuis combien de temps ?
- Un peu plus de 15 ans
Ha ! Bon, il a qu'une année de plus d'expérience que nous, ça passe !
- J'ai un peu un truc de ouf à faire là
T'as un truc de ouf ?
Ouais
Mec c'est trop bien ! J'te suis ?
Vas-y !
Ouf, on sent le... on sent l'animal !
- Tiens j'te donne ça
Ha, c'est un truc compliqué genre là on part sur une chirurgie et ça c'est pour désinfecter les instruments...
Tiens
Ha... ouais pour essuyer le...  les écoulements de sang... et de ...
Nan nan, le caca
Ohlala, il est pas content, bon j'avoue j'ai pas besoin de cet instrument
Alors ou t'as chié ? Ha il a pas de merde lui !
- Il a été nettoyé !
Hein, c'est mon jour de chance, Mickael, je sais que tu voulais me bizuter, et tu as raison : j'ai une tête a être bizuté
Mais il n'a pas chié, du coup je suis bien !
Merci mon pote !
- Le prochain caca c'est pour Lucas
Tu l'entends mec ? Il a dit "Le prochain caca c'est pour Lucas" c'est incroyable
Ok les amis, première consultation, on va voir ce qu'il faut faire
- Donc enfaite, c'est une petite chienne de 11 ans que je suis depuis... pas mal de temps ! Pour un problème de foie
Un problème de foie...
- Une hépatite chronique
- Et elle allait super bien, sauf que noël est passé par là
Ouais
- Elle a du manger un peu n'importe quoi
*rires*
Un petit foie gras qui a du tombé d'une assiette, elle l'a repéré bon, on sait ce que c'est les chiens !
- Et du coup diarrhée avec du sang depuis ce matin
- Juste ce matin
Donc, c'est une prise de sang pour contrôler le foie ?
Ouais
Ok, sa marche !
- T'es prêt ?
Je suis grave prêt
- Mais c'est pas toi qui va la faire !
Ouais !
*rires*
Moi je suis prêt a nettoyer le caca, ça ira ! Ça je peux y arriver
Cette prise de sang c'est très bien passé
Ça peut paraître impressionnant au début parce que le chien remue un peu
Mais elle a été splendide
C'est bien ma grande !
Ok la prise de sang est clean heu, docteur
Mickael vient de m'expliquer un truc très intéressant, en fait si la langue sort, c'est parce qu'elle n'a plus de dents
Sa langue n'est plus retenue par les dents donc elle sort
Donc quand un chien a la langue qui sort c'est qu'il a plus de dents !
- C'est ça !
Putainnn c'est marrant ! Mais c'est trop mignon en vrai !
Comme elle a plus de dents heu...
- Attends, juste deux secondes
J'entends pas !
Pardon excuse moi !
Donc la, on a controlé que le foie
Ouais, parce que c'est son problème chronique
- Son problème chronique, la première piste c'était ça !
- C'est ça, j'allais pas commencer à contrôler les reins ou la tyroïde
Ouais, ouais, ouais
- Je sais qu'elle a un problème de foie, elle a de la diarrhée, ça peut etre secondaire !
Sauf que là, c'est parfait, elle va être très contente
C'est vrai ?
- Ouais
Ho putain on va lui faire un calin, aller on va lui rouler une pelle avec sa langue
Elle est incroyable !
*rires*
Je lui avait dit que je lui ferai un bisou
C'est chose faite !
Shirukyyyy ~
De selle !
Shiruky t'es mon gars sûr !
Je le soupçonne  très fortement de regarder mes vidéos en cachette et de kiffer !
Je pense vraiment, vraiment qu'il s'est abonné !
Est ce que ce chien fait ma taille ?
Oui !
Bon on est sur une chienne qui est assez vieille, qui est essoufflée depuis ce matin...
Elle a pas l'air bien, elle a pas l'air bien !
M : Elle peut pas se lever, elle est vraiment essoufflée...
Lucas : Tu l'as touchée un peu ?
M : Ouais... Mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça vienne du coeur...
L : Généralement ça vient du coeur quand ils sont vieux, le coeur fatigue ?
M : Le coeur qui fatigue et c'est surtout que c'est un grand chien, et les grands chiens ont quand même très souvent des pathologies cardiaques
M : Sauf que là...
... J'ai quand même l'impression qu'elle a un gros ventre...
Lucas : Ah, donc elle aurait quelque chose dans le ventre ?
M : J'ai peur qu'elle ai du liquide dans le ventre...
Si c'est ça, il va falloir qu'on aille vérifier en écho(graphie)
L : Ok
M : Si y'a du liquide il va falloir qu'on le ponctionne
Les grands chiens font des cancers de la rate assez fréquemment
Lucas : D'accord..
M : Et ça peut saigner... du coup elle ferai une hémorragie interne.
L : Ok donc là le premier truc a faire c'est l'échographie pour voir ce  qu'il y a dans le ventre,  pour voir ce qu'il y a là dedans
M : Exactement
Lucas : Et ben allons y !
C'est ça ce qui est ouf avec ce métier c'est que tu as un animal qui va devoir soigner mais il peut pas parler ! Il peut pas te dire :
"Ouais j'ai mal là, je me sens pas très bien"
Donc du coup y'a tout un protocole à suivre pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'elle a et trouver ce qui va pas !
Et c'est ça qu'est dur en fait ! C'est de la recherche tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps !
Bon Mickael ça fait 15 ans qu'il fait ça donc il est très bon donc ça va être très intéressant de le suivre faire ça
Mais moi par exemple là je ne saurai pas par où commencer quoi
Vraiment, c'est... c'est dur !
Pour faire une écho(graphie)  on est obligés de raser le ventre pour pas qu'il y ait les poils entre l'appareil et le ventre
Ces grands poils là vont partir
Bon les amis, apparemment le coeur est un peu fatigué
Elle est vieille c'est normal hein, comme pour un humain
Maintenant Michael veut checker si les poumons vont bien
Et pour ça on va faire une radio
Je prie ! Ça me ferais trop mal au cœur parce que le monsieur il aime trop sa chienne
Il l'appelle ma fille comme moi j'appelle Natsu mon fils
Et du coup je comprends trop ce qu'il ressent et j'espère trop que la vie de cette chienne va continuer quoi,  tout simplement.
Mickael, fin de l'analyse de salive
Des bonnes nouvelles déjà .
Des bonnes nouvelles. on avait peur et tout que se soit ...
Qu 'elle est vielle, qu'elle heu...
vu qu'elle a ... qu'elle respire très vite et tout .
Elle respire très vite et puis on avais l'impression qu'elle avait un gros ventre ...
En fait c'était que du gras .
C'est bien de manger . Mangez à noël, y a pas de soucis
Ceci dit, elle a quand même un cœur qu'est très fatigué
Ouais ...